this week's episode is brought to you in
part by the sounds of science podcast
Eureka it's the sound of discovery but
what does it take to get there from the
Charles River Eureka blog comes a new
monthly podcast called sounds of science
each episode features a scientist
looking for their elusive Eureka moment
sounds of science explores the process
leading up to the latest breakthroughs
and the challenges that still remain
subscribe to sounds of science on Apple
podcast stitcher or wherever you get
your podcast this week's episode is also
brought to you in part by the American
Dental Association teeth tell a story we
know what ancient civilizations ate
drank even where they lived all from
looking at their teeth what story will
your teeth tell about you you're ad a
dentist can help you find out and give
you the tools to keep your teeth healthy
for years to come use the American
Dental Association's find a dentist tool
to find the right dentist for you go to
a DA org slash science mag today
welcome to the science podcast for
November 30th 2018 I'm Sara Krusty and
this week's show I talk with staff
writer Lisbon EC about the evolution of
plasticity what does it mean that some
animals some organisms have a little
wiggle room in their genomes Meghan
Cantwell talks with Marko a yellow about
a new method used to determine the
history of star formation in the
universe and for this month's book
segment Jen gold back talks with
Christine Dubois about her book the
story of soy I've got Elizabeth penny
see here with me she's a staff writer
for science and this week she wrote a
feature on how plastic traits get fixed
in animals and I guess more than animals
in genomes I'm Sarah Crespi hi Liz hi so
this is kind of a complicated topic but
you have a couple really good examples
in your story let's talk about this side
blotched lizard that can be different
kinds of colors can you set that up for
us okay so cyclic lizards are these
lizards that live in the southwest
mostly in desert environments they can
change their color to match their
environment and do they change it right
away like a chameleon not quite it can
take a couple of weeks to completely
change over depending on how much
contrast there is between where they
were and where they are now are mostly
their color ranges from sandy tan to
maybe a brownish color of the rocks but
in the Mojave Desert there's this black
lava flow that some lizards have decided
to live on and what researchers have
shown is that the lizards living on the
black lava are blacker get blacker than
the lizards that live on the sand most
of the time there's a trait that they
have in their genes that is somewhat
flexible it's influenced by the
environment while the animals alive they
can be lighter or they can be darker but
then sometimes that flexibility get
eliminated and they go to like dark
lizard or light lizard right in this
case the flexibility wasn't eliminated
it just shifted a little bit so what the
researchers found is that the lizards
that live on the lava when you stick
them back on a light surface they get
light but they don't get as light as the
lizards that live on the light surface
and when they stick those lizards on the
lava they get darker than the lizards
that live on the light surfaces can get
and so what you've seen is a genetic
shift in the color range of these
lizards so they're flexible but that
flexibility is being changed over time
correct very cool so let's talk about
Lamarck for one second it's introduced
in your story and people always bring it
up when they talked about adaptation of
living organisms so jean-baptiste
Lamarck was a French naturalist with his
own ideas about how evolution worked the
things that happened in the lifespan of
the parents were passed down to the
offspring but that's not what's
happening here
so Lamarck's idea was that you could
acquire a characteristic so say a
giraffe could get a longer neck because
he was reaching for leaves during his
lifetime and that longer neck would be
passed down to the offspring and of
course now we know that that's not how
evolution really works on the surface
when you think about what happened to
these lizards you can think well maybe
it is how evolution works but it's not
in this case the quote-unquote acquired
trait is really just a plastic trade and
the plasticity of being able to be dark
or be light is built into the genes and
that's driven by adaptation so there are
dark dark lizards and dark ish lizards
and the dark dark ones survive the ones
that can reach that darkness peak and so
they're selected for right okay right
the darker the better now let's go
really small so researchers were able to
observe this kind of thing in real time
by using fast breeding organisms like
yeast can you describe those experiments
from what they showed sure so these
researchers do what's called
experimental
solution in single-cell organisms in
this case yeast and they changed the
conditions under which they're growing
the yeast to see the effect on their
evolution so in this particular
experiment the researchers exposed yeast
to paraquat which is a toxin that causes
the cells to make excess oxygen free
radicals which damage DNA and just
generally hurt the cell when they
exposed the yeast to this toxin these
grew much slower but over time the yeast
began to recover their normal growth
weight this adaptation they decided was
a plastic adaptation in other words an
example of plasticity because when they
took the paraquat away for a while and
then re exposed the yeast of paraquat
the yeast were still in trouble right so
they could respond to this insole and
change something about themselves but
that went away when the insult was
removed correct and there probably
wasn't enough time for a mutation that
was we know somewhere randomly in that
population to take over save these
organisms and then go away correct
okay in your story you mentioned a few
cases where this has been seen in the
wild and also this laboratory example
but how common overall is this
phenomenon well for one I think we
probably have more options than we
realize as people studied climate change
and the effects of climate change on
plants and animals they realized that
plants can adjust yeah and that
adjustment is part of their plasticity
at least to some degree they can adjust
so what the plants are doing are
responding to their environment and
everybody has built into their genes
some ability to respond to the
environment
now if the environment changes in some
permanent way then the organisms that
have the greatest ability to adapt to
that environment will do best they'll
produce more young and eventually there
could be a genetic change to sort of
solidify or
six that particular form of the trait in
that organism now you ask why doesn't
that happen all the time it probably is
happening all the time and we don't
realize it what are the trade-offs
between having a lot of plasticity in
your genome carrying a lot of options
around with you and not having that like
why why wouldn't we just have a ton of
options and in all our genes there is a
cost to being plastic basically if you
can adapt to a lot of different
environments you're probably not really
great at anyone right so you lose
specialization at the cost of being this
flexible right this is a very similar
process but it's much faster than say a
mutation arising random mutations occur
pretty slowly so if you have an
environment that's changing really fast
you can't evolve ie mutate really fast
enough to keep up with the changes but
if you have plasticity then you can
basically depend on that plastic
response to make it so that you can
survive at least somewhat in the
environment long enough for a mutation
to occur I brought up Lamarck before
because I think that this idea some
people might think this is you know
adopting Lamarckian evolution what is it
is it a controversial idea if you make
this distinction between what he said
and what people are saying here it's
been somewhat controversial mainly
because I think people don't really
understand exactly how plasticity can
work to help facilitate evolution but I
think there are more and more examples
that research finding and the other
thing that's helpful to is they're
finding the genes that are underlying
the changes that they see in the
organisms so there is a genetic
explanation all right Lucy thank you so
much for talking with me hey well thank
you have a nice day Elizabeth Konishi is
a staff writer for science you can read
her story at science mad or news stay
tuned for Megan Cantwell's interview
with Marco alo about the history of star
formation
[Music]
this week's episode is also brought to
you by ops Cheney by Atlassian incidents
happen and they require complex
coordination between operations and
software development teams who are
putting out fires every day that's why
getting alerts immediately is critical
thankfully there's ops Cheney by Alaskan
ops genie empowers dev and ops teams to
plan for service disruptions and stay in
control during incidents it also gives
teams the power to respond quickly and
efficiently to unplanned issues and
helps to notify all the right people
through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation pass an
account for things like time zones and
holidays
better yet ops genie allows for deep
flexibility how when and where alerts
are deployed with over 200 integrations
like JIRA Amazon CloudWatch
data dog new relic and more plus it
tracks all activity and provides useful
insights to improve future incident
responses with offs Genie your next
incident doesn't stand a chance
visit ops Genie comm to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members that's ops Genie calm o-p-s
GE n IE comm never miss a critical alert
again with ops genie
[Music]
I'm Megan Cantwell and I'm with Marco
yaho to talk about a new approach to
determining the history of star
formation all the way since the Big Bang
hey Marco Amy Gunn what is the
importance of understanding
star-formation history
well star-formation history is one of
those incredibly useful and incredibly
important quantities
everything depends on stars at the end
all the light that we see in the UV
optical and infrared is emitted by stars
and all the AV elements other than
helium and hydrogen are being basically
synthesizing stars so understanding
stellar evolution across the history of
the universe is one of those fundamental
problems this isn't the first
determination of the universe's
star-formation history right how many
other models have there been there have
been quite a few of them because it's
something very important but all the
other methods of measuring the star
formation rate of the universe rely on
just one way to do that which is
basically detecting galaxies in very
deep observations for example by the
Apple Space Telescope how were these
reconstructions limited they're limited
to the fact that anything that has not
been detected in those d fields cannot
be accounted for so galaxies that are
just too faint to be detected even by
Hubble we know those exist they cannot
be accounted for and also there is star
formation that happens a really far away
from the galaxy centers and that's too
faint to be detected in galaxy surveys
which brings us to your team's approach
which estimated the star formation
history by observing over 700 Blazers
could you explain what a blazar is and
how observing them helped you
reconstruct the history of star
formation Blazers are supermassive black
holes at the center of massive typically
elliptical galaxies and these black
holes are creating some gases so they
are being fed some gas and they are able
somehow to accelerate particles to near
the speed of light these particles have
made all kinds of light in particularly
meet a lot of gamma rays please use
these objects as probes of the extra
epigram light so our goal in this
project was actually to measure the
entire
output of the universe emitted by stars
every star that's ever existed leaves an
imprint on the galaxy which is what this
extra galactic backlight you mentioned
is so how did you measure this backlight
this kind of light the star light acts
as a fog for gamma rays that are
traveling through space so there is a
process known to particle physicists
which is the pair creation process in
this process you can have two photons so
two particles of light interacting with
each other in disappearing creating an
electron-positron pair in our case we
have one of the gamma ray emitted by the
Blazers while traveling through space is
a non negligible chance to interact with
one of those photons from stars and
being absorbed we see how many of those
photons from lasers have been absorbed
to quantify our thick is this fog of
starlight photons the thicker it is the
more photons from lasers have been
absorbed
how does determining the thickness of
the fog allow you to model the star
formation rate we are able using Blazers
some 739 Blazers across basically a
large fraction of this way the universe
we can actually reconstruct how much
light there was at any point in time
these are the universe entry frequencies
to different wavelengths the optical the
ultraviolet and then your infrared and
we can convert these relatively easily
with standard knowledge to the activity
star formation activity as a function of
age in the universe if you have UV light
the ultraviolet light is emitted by
massive stars these are extremely short
leave the stars or so whenever you see
this light this means there has been
recent star formation once you observe
this UV light this can be transformed
into star formation rate rather quickly
accounting for all the stars they are
not seen simply because they're less
massive and miss luminous and also
accounting for the absorption of light
by dust which is a process that happens
this is all possible because of the
Fermi gamma-ray telescope what about
this telescope is so unique that allows
this approach it is the only gamma-ray
telescope in space there are no other
instruments that surveyed in the same
energy band and there are some gamma-ray
telescopes from the ground
the thing is that you need to be in
space if you want to be able to detect
photons of the right gamma ray energy
which is around between 10 Giga electron
volts and 100 Giga electron volts so
this means roughly 10 200 times the
energy of visible light because those
are the ones that interact with the UV
photons from stars which is extremely
important to measure star formation rate
across these three of the universe yeah
and what were the advantages of this
approach to determining star-formation
history as opposed to past approaches it
is a more comprehensive approach so we
measure all the light that ever existed
all the light I was ever emitted and
this means if there are galaxies that
Hubble for example is not detected yet
because they're too faint that they lied
still still exist still in the
extractive economic is still in this
common starlight so we're sensitive to
all the things that other instruments
and other approaches have not seen so
how has the rate of star formation
changed into the Big Bang in the first
million years of the universe the
universe already was able to form stars
and then he started forming stars are
much larger rate so it became a lot more
efficient doing that it turns out that
you've reached a peak efficiency in in
forming stars roughly five billion years
after the Big Bang or eight billion
years ago this is the point in time when
the universe was forming stars with a
very large rate from the point on they
start formation rate of the universe has
declined and this is due to many too
many things one of them is the fact that
a lot of all the available gas in
galaxies has been dressed forming two
stars and shortleaf stars like that like
our Sun or even less massive than our
Sun are fairly long-lived so they they
lock the gas in stars ultimately your
reconstruction was pretty similar to
past ones correct it is it is very
similar and it is in very good agreement
so what is the next step with your
research does your team plan on using
the Fermi telescope to explore another
aspect of the universe I think at this
point we have exploited as much as
possible the Fermi telescopes in order
to constrain exactly background light
but the reason there is a
limitation the fact that if you want to
constrain the exact typical online to
longer wavelengths which means more to
what's the infrared those photons not
detected by the large area telescope on
board offer me anymore but those photos
are detected by telescopes on the
grounds and these are they this were
called air check of telescopes so our
next goal is basically to use data from
those telescopes and continue to measure
out the Starlight particular extending a
measurement in the infrared regime and
is very important for the process of
dust absorption for example all right
thank you so much Marco Marco Alejo is
an assistant professor of physics and
astronomy at Clemson University you can
find a link to his research at science
mag slash podcasts next up we've got
this month's book segment listen to Jen
go back and author Christine Dubois
discuss her book the story of soy hi
everyone and welcome to this month's
book segment of the podcast if you're a
vegetarian like me you'll be noshing on
a delicious soy based turkey substitute
for your big feast this month and that's
why we're reading dr. Christine m.d. was
new book the story of soy I'm joined by
Christine Dubois and I'd like to start
by saying that I have a sort of intimate
personal relationship with soy I eat a
lot of it as a vegetarian but I also
grew up in rural Illinois surrounded by
soybeans that said I didn't know a lot
about its history or the tremendous
scope of its global impact until I read
your book can you start by giving us an
overview of the breadth of what you
cover so my book the story of soy you
might consider it a biography of soy soy
were a person this would be their
biography starting from its early
domestication moving through its use in
Chinese and Japanese Buddhism its
development to use during various Wars
including the russo-japanese war and
world war two and then its use in
factory farming of pigs and chickens
primarily on through its genetic
engineering its use in biodiesel and its
environmental effects as well as its
effects on human nutrition
in the book you take deep dives into
different parts of SOI sister II and the
role it played in Wars societal
development politics in the environment
if we go into any of those though I
think we'll lose the big picture so can
you summarize just how important this
little beam is on a global scale
soybeans are one of the most traded
crops around the world
most people have no idea how incredibly
important this plant is because it is
fed primarily to chickens and pigs on
large factory farms with relatively few
employees so most people especially
people who live in cities are not aware
of how in agricultural areas
particularly in North and South America
this crop is huge it's hugely profitable
and it is hugely shaping our world it
was the first commercially really
successful genetically engineered crop
and because it was so commercially
successful
it has spurred the development of other
genetically engineered crops it is used
in countless products both industrial
products and many many food products
although in very small quantities so
it's everywhere in our environment and
it has everything to do with
cutting-edge science and it is massively
important to economies and trade
disputes let me pick up on that trade
dispute item because a few weeks ago The
Washington Post had a really interesting
piece on how North Dakota soy farmers
were being especially hard hit by the
tariffs implemented as part of this
ongoing us-china trade war because they
sell the vast majority of their crop to
China do you see that that loss of
access to US markets whether it's
temporary or long term is going to have
a worldwide impact like well other
countries start growing more soy and
what would that mean the way soy is
being handled as a crop worldwide
especially in South America right now
and it's really a looming problem for
Africa as well is often quite
environmentally destructive the only
reason I'm not mentioned North America
here is that we already destroyed the
North American prairies
long time ago even before soy was
planted there so it's a done deal
here in North America but in South
America there's a lot of land that was
still virgin wilderness that is being
divorce it ordesa vanad in order to grow
soy because it is such a lucrative crop
and it's really a very very serious
problem particularly in places like
Paraguay which have much less strict
environmental regulation and places like
Brazil which has increasingly strict
environmental regulation to protect the
Amazon but which has very difficult
problems of enforcement Cargill and the
Nature Conservancy have worked together
to try to improve some of the systems
for protecting the Amazon but there's
such a long way to go and some of the
things that are being done to assist the
soy farmers of Brazil in particular the
completion of a highway that cuts right
through the Amazon is which is a
national highway is really leading to
deforestation along its borders within
50 miles of any major road you get a lot
of people coming in building all the
things that would service the truck
drivers and then town spring up and then
when town spring up you have to have
schools and hardware stores and churches
and so forth and more and more gets
built up along a highway so there's a
very deep concern and of course the
concern relates to how is all of this
going to affect global warming and right
now with what's going on with the United
States trade war with China we have
slapped a 25% tariff onto our soy being
exported to China which is our largest
buyer and so right now the Chinese don't
have a lot of options for making up that
soy but in the long run they are going
to want to look for other suppliers that
are not going to be slapping that tariff
on them and so they are investing as
they already happen but they're probably
going to accelerate it now investing in
more virgin lands in Africa and South
America
but they're really doing a lot in Africa
that are
probably gonna start being planted in
soy and so more wildernesses are going
to be destroyed and this is a very grave
concern for climate change Christine
Dubois her new book is the story of soy
and it's out this month we'd love to
hear your comments on the science
magazine books vlog books at all have a
happy holiday however much soy it may
contain and we'll be back in December
with more books and that concludes this
edition of the science podcast if you
have any comments or suggestions for the
show write to us at science podcast at
AAAS o RG you can subscribe to the show
anywhere you get your podcast or you can
listen on the science website at science
mag org slash podcasts to place an ad on
the science podcast contact mid-roll com
the show was produced by Sarah Crespi as
Megan Cantwell and edited by Potter G
Jeffrey cook composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and its
publisher Triple S thanks for joining us